I think I was supposed to talk about my new book, which is called "Blink,"...
...and it's about snap judgments and first impressions...
...and it comes out in January and I hope you all buy it in triplicate.
But I was thinking about this...
...and I realized that although my new book makes me happy,...
...and I think will make my mother happy, it's not really about happiness.
So I decided instead, I would talk about someone who I think has done as much...
...to make Americans happy as perhaps anyone over the last 20 years,...
...a man who is a great personal hero of mine,...
...someone by the name of Howard Moskowitz, who is most famous for reinventing spaghetti sauce.
Howard's about this high, and he's round, and he's in his 60s,...
...and he has big huge glasses and thinning grey hair,...
...and he has a kind of wonderful exuberance and vitality,...
...and he has a parrot and he loves the opera,...
...and he's a great aficionado of medieval history.
And by profession, he's a psychophysicist.
Now, I should tell you that I have no idea what psychophysics is,...
...although at some point in my life,...
...I dated a girl for two years, who was getting her doctorate in psychophysics,...
...which should tell you something about that relationship.
As far as I know, psychophysics is about measuring things.